you know him he's one of the Impractical
Jokers and this guy has probably made
more people laugh than anybody maybe any
I'm trying to think of somebody that
tickles people that's real famous I
don't even know but he's probably one of
the top 40 or 50 funniest people that
you've probably ever even heard of her
not heard of and he's here today he has
a new show on TBS called misery index
he has countless seasons of his hit show
the Impractical Jokers he's one of the
tenderloins and that's uh their original
group of improv estate and gentlemen my
guest my friend mr. Joe Gatto or Gatto
I'm not sure I'm gonna ask him right now
[Music]
what island is that how does that rank
amongst other Island oh they call it the
other Caribbean of of the New York
Harbor that's cool I know that yeah I
gotta go to Staten Island me you never
been there's no I don't think I've been
there I mean I always hear you guys talk
about it you know and you hear a lot of
people talk about it you know most
people go through it yeah it's like it's
the connector between Brooklyn and
Jersey or Long Island in Jersey you know
so people love people go through it but
a lot of people
it's the freeway to see the Statue of
Liberty oh really
yeah you think that's that on ferry
which is free yeah as opposed to the
Liberty ferry which takes you to Liberty
Island and you have to get off and look
at the like the feet of it and when
you're there there's like nothing to do
so you can get a good look at it right
yeah the best look from the ferry so you
see everybody on one side of the boat on
the way there and then one side of the
boat on the way dude used to work on the
ferritin you weren't know did you work
on a ferry ever time was tough so yeah I
Panhandle for no no no I don't work on
the ferry yeah I thought somebody told
me that Oh what was a job that you had
that uh that you actually miss that was
a long time ago
I love sales sales all the time yeah I
when I came out here to chase the dream
I was gonna be a screenwriter director
that's what that's our hope I'm hoping
to end up and I came out here do that in
2003 205 and I ended up working at
Nordstrom's at the Grove oh wow and I
crushed the retail game for a while you
you really yeah CrossFit what was like
one of your go-to moves just somebody
wandered in like you know I'd always we
I worked in the rail which is the men's
section it sounded like high-end jeans
and like is that right yeah so I well
that's a quality second it's a quality
section yeah we actually put it on the
map I didn't know how to we're breaking
it was a platinum pay Center salesman
number five across the country Wylie
yeah 1 million dollars in a year but
that's neither here or there I mean
who's bragging no one and you guys just
telling some real wild stuff in there
yeah it was like it was like when Von
Dutch hats
I was every I put one on everybody even
newborn still that's it man you know $1
$1 it was a $60 hat it was yeah I used
to I used to do the thing because we
worked in the men's section when I had a
great scheme it's all Commission really
no hourly you don't get paid you don't
get paid if you don't sell right so that
was it which seems a little yeah I think
it is I think it is so I didn't hate it
that's like drugs it was like yes it's a
bond pass the Von Dutch so I did the I
had like girlfriends who were coming
with a boyfriend and when the boyfriends
would come to shop and I'm like oh and
you I'm sure you need some jeans to let
me take you upstairs and introduce you
to Chelsea I never go up there and I
would have a deal with Chelsea upstairs
like whatever you sell them I get 50% of
and it was such a great scheme cuz you
could sell anything in the store and
then eventually I became known there as
I was fond and funny you know and I
didn't really yeah ever good with people
and I would could sell anything so
wasn't like oh I need a watch I'm like I
know I know watches yeah I don't
I walk over I get a key from some guy
but I got you over here thank you get
the guy on NordicTrack on the fifth
floor they sell like Tesla's at the
Grove now yes a Tesla inside the
Nordstrom is a Tesla so I was like do
you guys could we sell soup stock I'll
go back forget TV man I'm coming back if
the self-test start one you make deals
all across the Grove it's you're
wandering out it's really just a
personal shopper tonight then I got a I
got recruited I got poached from
Nordstrom to this high-end it's called
HD buttercup it's a oh yeah monitor I
opened that store did you realize it I
was their first personal shopper dude
it's pricey crazy and I worked out a
deal with them that because they have
little their setup was called man you
tailors right so they have little stores
within a big store so it's like kind of
like that um Fred Segal yeah exactly
right so they had that whole setup and I
was like oh okay so I want to sell the
whole store and they're like oh no you
would just work this one company I'm
like oh that's not what I was told in
the interview and they're like what I
was like I'm just gonna sell everything
so I would just walk around and sell
everything to anybody who walked in the
door
yeah and I actually helped Jessica Alba
with like rugs like that was my big
thing for a while I like helped her like
it was issues they were her brother and
I
I would like some rugs and stuff and I
was at my claim to fame for a while I
went around I was like yeah I sold drugs
or Jessica like I you know I just jumped
it up magic carpet yeah we call but
there was a head of antique section and
there was one guy that were setting he
let her cut HD buttercup inside one of
the men who tells was an antique guy
okay and it's all Commission there too I
worked out a deal where was hourly plus
Commission so I got like 3% 5% they got
5% there and I said okay I was like you
know whatever I said I'll get 5% of and
this guy and I was like eating tuna fish
like you know what it's like when you
move out here like I had like a peanut
but I can't afford the jello is like
peanut butter sandwiches yeah you know
so I didn't squeeze the packet of jelly
in your mouth I would get a bite of the
virus in the squeeze yeah just fill your
pockets at any time ha splash that great
jelly to some please have shady jelly
yeah but that's a different chair I
don't know if you wants to get into that
now let's come back well circle let's
say so at HD buttercup you got the
energy
so what happened what was that what so I
don't know that I don't know [ __ ] about
antiques the guy goes on break he's like
hey I got to go pick up my daughter I
think I do pick up his daughter from
school or something do you mind just
watching us till we close
nobody everyone listen all the white
privilege and that guy's cool yeah pick
up whatever had to do or yeah doctor
appointment or funeral I can't remember
if these antique it is probably research
like let me go get a bureau right he
goes on break and a woman walks in I was
like oh could you help me with as you
like I'm looking for an antique chest I
don't make sure I saw I walk in and I
hadn't hardly ever walked into this
because I didn't know anything about it
yeah and there's only so much you could
fake right so I get in and she's like
yeah this is from a battle yeah I'd like
this at all oh this smells like a
Lincoln yeah this has got mahogany and
Lincoln that's right here of his
throwing out terms so she's like she
walked in and she fell in love with this
like armoire that's like big oh yeah
there's a real nice and I was like oh
this is what nice she's like all I think
my husband will like this it was like I
think was a good anniversary gift or
something
how's it go okay I was like I could get
you the information she's like oh no
I'll take it and his guys on lunch and I
work on Commission 5% and I'm like
alright and I look at the price it was
$40,000 and I was like where would you
like that delivered and that was like it
was put on your bags like I got a uber
for
it wasn't even that hairy this I will
walk all the Culver City from yeah oh
yeah you didn't know a couple Tongans
are Hawaiian so [ __ ] if you don't say
now it's before they came here there was
this furniture to stay there you move to
the furniture this is my dresser I live
here now yeah but that was that was my
big thing and then I moved back to New
York and and so whenever you move when
you made that move back to New York had
you like kind of given up on some of
that that like that dream a little bit
like was it a little bit of that move
yes I mean up we've all done a little
bit of that move at some point I think
like there was a point I was out here
for like six years and then I moved back
to Louisiana for a while and I was uh
doing margaritas or something or making
margaritas mmm first you know that a
[ __ ] a real halfway house of a [ __ ]
taco taco tyria you know it was like a
tacos like his little shady bag with
tacos and then they had a bar like hook
to it ruined yeah and they had the
margarita machine and I broke it I said
did the settings wrong and they met
Alberto Mike it wasn't broken it was
like Johnny Buffett's Margaritaville
[Laughter]
yeah it was like yeah I was like che
guevara margaritas you know that's
interesting yeah so when you move back
was it was it because of um when I moved
back my grandma passed away my
grandmother my mother became widows
together like within like five days of
each other so they always had each other
so my mom was like a lonely Oh so I felt
like you know and you know what I was
like it's at my grandmother's funeral
actually my hand was kind of forced at
my grandma's funeral I had come in from
LA and I said I said to my mom was like
you know maybe I'll move back to New
York just out loud like just streaming
cars oh maybe I'll move back to New York
in a little bit and she started crying
and hugging me said thank you thank you
think I was like okay I guess I'm moving
back to New York like I feel like back
off lady you know it sounds like I'll
move back so I decided and you guys are
pretty close your mom yeah we were yeah
so uh and so yes so at that point you
don't really have a choice then if she's
if you guys are close as we want you
back yeah so I came back and I moved
back into her basement as a good 30 year
old son's do the record flag yeah we
it's the same basement actually where
four eye moves where the tenderloins
used to rehearse might come boys we used
to rehearse down there me Sal Meyer and
our friend Mike used to before we dinner
shows the same basement so I ended up
living where I was doing improv
rehearsal so you know I was in a good
mental space and I ended up getting a
job because of out here in retail at
that one of the man you tailors there
uh-huh
brought me in to a show with the Jacob
Javits Center was just as big furniture
show at the Javits Center like what
people come to meet new you know vendors
and stuff okay where's Javits Center
it's an L it's in Manhattan
it's the big conference center there in
Manhattan so hey it's like the design
center here whatever you know like one
of those where they had those big
conferences huge you know Comic Con is
in New York right so um they uh I I
decided to work help her out with this
thing and I'm just you know selling
[ __ ] and you're just selling all the
stuff to people were coming into opening
stores and this one woman came up to me
her name was Ali and she was the CEO of
a new store called the giggle a baby
store hmm and so I started selling some
stuff and she like really like something
Oh baby shake it make sure it makes
noise don't shake the baby the toy Wow
kids nowadays they're resilient
yeah well the head is lady they had this
lady the other day and she goes man
these children her kid was being bad she
goes he children act like they've been
here before that's what she's sayin
well they got nothing to lose I don't
know any better yeah like that is kind
of true so they've been here yeah it's
funny cuz through my son and daughter
I'm always like oh like she acts super
different my daughter is for my son
steel and my two-year-old son acts
completely different than my
two-year-old daughter did like my
daughter's all prim and proper like you
go like you know go color and she'd sit
in the corner for four hours with ya
goin with a crayon yeah yeah the little
women I think they're yeah they have
they want to change the world you know
they have some inkling of like you know
hope and stuff and the boys are fine but
I wanted um just running around knocking
stuff over yeah that's my boy that's my
remark it's always crazy to watch me
like what is going on out there banana
you guys want to pull them over and be
like listen you don't know things yet
but this is what you're doing that
what's going on how you do it do my
little nephews to hide
pompous [ __ ] like on bookshelves and
shouldn't be real quiet and [ __ ]
surprise you bro yeah yeah he was like
19 months old I'm like that's insane
there's no way he got up there by
natural causes oh no he sorry so seek
that out this is we're gonna make some
hammer oh you could tell he'd definitely
been like in vision and being up on that
shelf we just woke up there one morning
no it's like no free solo baby right now
it's all about the angle yeah the most
damage that's strong
oh yeah dude he was really yeah there's
some of these children they're just wild
they got the Edgar Allan Poe in them you
know something's going on they got Dirty
Birds in the back of their brain yeah
but um
so now tenderloins now one story that I
love about you guys is a group of
Impractical Jokers is that tenderloins
is y'all's original group and was there
members that we don't know about with
her other members cuz you mentioned a
guy Mike yeah there's there was two that
we brought on one was Mike was the
original Mike Bochy I went to high
school with him as well and Quentin just
Quinn but you know qdk yeah he didn't go
that way and botch actually got a job
and grew up and he got married and
everything like before all of us like he
became a grown-up and the rest of us
were like trying to do improv and it
just didn't match with his schedule
anymore like we want to shoot like on a
Wednesday at like 5:00 you know four
o'clock is it guys I'm at work like what
are you talking about I can't be there
right he just kind of went the way and
was very successful and family and love
and money on his own why you know he
runs like he's in a pier in the PR and
stuff so we see him all time you know
nice little friends woman stuff Wow
is it kind of is it is it not hectic but
is it like is it interesting to think
like oh if he would have been there does
he ever like do you guys ever lament on
it a little bit I mean it was gonna LA
sitive way yeah yeah we always go down
like the what if like what if he was
there or what if there was five like
what if Q came around in him like it's
not more even like a Q or him it's more
like Oh what if because a lot of this
that week you was a huge part of the
puzzle for us cuz we had moved into
video write and script in writing stuff
and Q is a very strong writer and stuff
so he helped he helped us with that part
of the deal like the really different
kind of humor than us a little bit at
that time we were a lot really corny and
he was like you know fun corny like
people liked it but like he is like oh
what if we're like gave a little edge
you know yeah a little dark rich
sometimes were just fun to like yeah and
the combination of all of our
sensibilities I think really was the
right perfect
you know that I'm making a margarita
right you know that was the right if
you're making it yeah because the baby
powder like somebody and was so anybody
else was there there was a guy that
jumped in for a little bit Gideon who
was actor friend of ours I moved to New
York from Florida honey he filled in for
a little bit too and he was like a fifth
while Batra still with us it would there
would you ever get he ever done an
episode that that were you guys had them
pop in or any no we actually used
botches daughter Sienna in one of the
times where sometimes we take it to the
park and we have our daughter or like it
as an actress away and we use botches
daughters alright we did it we did it
twice we did something we just did
something recently weather I don't think
aired yet with her as well we brought
her back to like surprise sounds okay
yeah that's cool yeah so they're in the
mix you know we see you know talk and
stuff but it's it's fun that you know
the tenderloins is really what I came
back to so like when I didn't you got
back home you got a deficit in DeLong
yeah we came back in and I was like okay
so I'm back now because when I was away
for two years like we didn't do any live
shell Dylan did a show when I came home
so I came home I think he did two or
three shows where I came home I'm like
hey I'm homeless pretty show up and
ready to improv show up and we'd go and
do it it was that it was kind of defunct
it didn't really right yeah yeah you had
everybody there yeah so now I was like
Joe's back he's like you are what are we
doing and then we got into like that's
when myspace took off and all the like
you know sketch comedy on the Internet
yeah so we start doing sketches and what
about videos neguin oh uh what is a
Tenderloin what is it I know a
tenderloin is a meat yeah it's a meat
eater
it's a cut of meat okay what is it can
you look that up do you mind I want to
see what cut this thing is so I know so
you good but it's I just want to
visualize yeah what's going on here the
tender is part of a loin pork loin of
beef pork etc yeah
so that's probably Sal yeah taken from
under the short ribs in the hindquarter
nine quarters that's Marco everybody
right this is this is this is the good
one let's go to the second a district of
a city where vice and corruption promise
you
we just missing me I guess I'm the I
guess on the short ribs well yeah
because in San Francisco there's a
famous [ __ ] went down and the story
drugs dude I accept video on my phone of
some people blowing each other from our
hotel window yeah here yeah we we we had
walked by when we did the San Francisco
sketch fest back in the day and we were
staying and we thought it'd be funny
that time the Lord saying attend I said
not knowing right so we're walking back
from a 7-eleven that had had iron you
know iron events and like the aunt like
you had to come in to a 7-eleven which I
was like this is not good bulletproof
glass like to enter like you went into
like a little thing to walk around it
was bulletproof a little car like a gold
Pope car taken year round what you
makalah's row you want to watch him what
came back and there was just we walked
down one Street I'm not even kidding
there was just like three separate
things of [ __ ] going on and like and
there was a it was like two cops that
were like looking at like a body just
like this and we were like and we didn't
know if the goose dead or just passed
out and then we walked back to our hotel
room like that might have been a murder
scene out they just found it was like oh
well Jim here we go we got to find out
yeah yeah we're gonna start it up yeah
that 10 I went crazy man I remember we
went to this thing called beta breakers
a while back there and it was like this
it was a race I guess where people start
I guess at the bay and then they run
like the bridge or something yeah well
we did a bunch of mushrooms and we
didn't I don't know if we weren't really
in the race or anything
but at one point we took over a table
somebody had a table where they had all
the cups of water and we took it over
right in the middle and I'm just just
flying on mushrooms at this point dude I
mean I'm look you know the Lord's
looking for me you know when I'm looking
for him you know we're gonna meet up
that afternoon but uh and people were
running by in this race you know it's
tens of thousands people in this race
and when they get close someone would
get would try to get the water and we
were like no it's for Asian people only
so you had so many people and they're
running they have to keep going there's
a huge flow of people they can't argue
or discuss it he like notations only
they're like
and escape from dehydration a quarter
mile down the road these Irish people
waking up at the curb at the next turn
just from whom and on Asian people with
so happy I am ro it was so bizarre so
it's a great choice ooh we thought we
laughter so we just sat there somebody
had deserted their stanbro you know what
I'm saying this was like you know this
you get probably you know hindquarter
back in the military for this somebody
deserted their you know their water
stand and we just took it over to where
a mushroom we're just serving it out a
deserted stand as a way I made a lot of
my jokes early in Korea not even like a
girl just me being me with my friends
like you because you're so I was a host
at any restaurant where the good thing
was oh and I would go as far as I could
like I there was a Perkins by me and
stand out yeah so I mean I and I could
literally end up working the whole
burgers like I walk in and be like you
know 11 o'clock at night people walk in
I'm like how many and they're like well
if you say how many to anyone anywhere
with authority you'll get an answer and
I promise you that you could be anywhere
how many in your party to take to go
hang up not know what to do these people
waiting didn't gotta care Sal used to
hate there was two things Sal used to
know it embarrassed him oh my god the
worst layer but he loved it and hated it
but there was two things he used to hate
the worst one was taking an elevator
with me uh-huh because I would just I
didn't give me and then two he's like
God how many floors yeah there's all
talked to was uh what he called to was
waiting for a table to restaurant me
because I can when I'm in a waiting
situation hey I get bored and I'm like
what can I do here that's gotta be fun
for me I don't even care of other people
watching or later I just like do stuff
for myself after time right and then
they would enjoy watching that you know
so did you oh did you do that kind of
stuff when you were a kid is it
instigation you think that you kind of
like or is it I'm kind of thinking what
the element is that I didn't do I didn't
is it a surprise is it instigation like
what is the thing that turned that that
attracts you
you know to do that sort of I'm just
trying to think of the thing in your
head it's like well I wasn't like that
all grown up I was super geeky I was it
was until junior high school and I said
the first time I did improv at high
school we did high school improv
together that is that it made me go to
it like he's like you should come you're
funny I just have lunch from all-time so
get funny you should come and try it as
like now and as I couldn't do it and
then in high school I got bullied a
little bit and stuff and I used it I
turned the tables in high school because
I I would reverse bully the the football
players uh-huh like I remember the
moment where one guy walked by and like
they said some whatever and I knocked
the books out of the linebackers hand
like on a phone and what made em up like
that and he legs and I'm sorry sure and
he picked them on better and I walked
away everybody lost it laughing and it's
like oh you know what I'm gonna do this
and I just started like bullying like I
was crying for pounds on the math team
bowling team like I was like not
anything right so on the bullying team
yeah some schools have a big take you
know that's part of the problem I think
in America yeah bullying so you said you
just kind of said oh I'm flip the script
so I did that and I was like oh that was
kind of the way I dealt with it slash
and made me feel good and then also the
thing that really liked about it was it
really took a turn to the whole high
school we won't you know our class we
went to old boy Catholic High School so
what are you doing besides mess meet you
at the part right art right there are
300 people in the class and I really
felt a moment there where it's like oh
everybody's having fun with this yeah
there's like kind of like bullying kind
of like one away from my class it kind
of was just like oh we're all just
[ __ ] around together like it didn't
matter like so I felt like that was
pretty cool
oh that's cool and that is kind of like
carried me throughout my whole career
all the way to here now that's a big
thing for me but I was a perceptional
most yeah it was perception and then I
was like that gave me like a weird
confidence and I think confidence is
definitely my key like I I'll try to
pull off anything I don't you know yeah
yeah
strange to being strange because I
remember seeing you at the Wild West
Comedy fast and I knew about you guys as
a group but I'd never spend any time
with any of you yeah that's where we met
you yeah that's what I met yet yeah and
so we're at some bar after party and and
all your cruise all raging and stuff and
having fun and and the life of the party
I mean the group and there's one guy
who's just I think that's all when
gonna take it was on or something right
and there's one guy who's standing on a
table like right up against the wall
facing them all just beating the wall
dude and nobody else has really kind of
involved in what he's doing right but
he's like this interview
it's like he's this hot ornament this
Christmas ornament in the middle of
summer bro you know Dan I said damn that
guy's [ __ ]
I don't drink don't smoke in my life
I've never even tried a cigarette
everybody thinks I am so like high on
coke oh I was like that guy's energy my
body shouldn't have like I just go but
cuz what I love about that moment is
that gets anyone licensed in the room to
be weird because I'm gonna be weirder
don't even worry about it because you'd
always be like what you're not that guy
like that's the guy I am in a party it's
like I could be earlier this side he's
crazy
Sal spent most of his life explaining
that I wasn't trying people like that's
really we'd have to do when we go out
even like these guys like shirts off
he's doing the worm in the middle of the
club throw hot models like I don't care
anything yeah yeah was inspiring kind I
was like oh man I wanna have that much
fun yeah I think that's probably what
people get when they watch your show
some or when they watch of Joker's and
watched it over the years it's like oh I
wanna have that much fun I guess well
are we you know the show quickly became
not anything about like pranks or
anything became just friendship on
display yeah and that's what people
really took to and that's why you know
everybody always feels like they know
that friend like if you watch the show
and you didn't know us I imagine you'd
be able like oh I got a guy like Sal I
know a guy like well nobody's really got
a Mar but yeah I got a guy like him you
know in your career clique or growing up
so I think this part of that that people
really that talks to people
yeah do you um when you when you when
you think about like kind of like the
next steps and stuff cuz at a certain
point like you guys have all grown so
much you know does it start to see you I
know you have the new show now that
you're doing the misery index and but do
you mention directing as stuff early do
you start to like think about things
like that you know yeah hundra's i'm
yeah i've always had I never wanted I
never thought this would be and I never
want to be in front
trying to [ __ ] work at Nordstrom yeah
trying to sell high-end t-shirts what a
guy work his pima cotton you know but uh
I try to get FEMA cotton to the people
but I I did like I always always behind
the camera guy always directing
producing that's always what I wanted to
do even the ten to one stuff like I
always did like it was like like one of
our most famous sketches I'm not I'm
barely in because I was like directing
and like I love editing and all that
stuff right but and even with this show
like that's what I do like I I help
short run this hotel oh okay you did my
job I was the first one had to quit my
job full-time so I kind of got like I
was like guys are we doing this because
I gotta give up on giggle like I had to
quit giggle everybody else was able to
work both jobs queue was still farming
Sal still owned his it was still parked
under me oh let's say look still a
fireman is a unique term as well I'm not
saying I love firemen right yeah
especially if there's a fire no one
person you want to see they're basically
people that are training for the hot dog
eating good people at heart it's awful
that's a professional service cuss in
sports like that's what they do you know
but they you know so he was everybody
had their job to fall back on and I was
like do I have to be all in when we shot
the pilot she gave me two weeks off and
then when it was like hey you gotta
shoot the first season you need we're
gonna do it over the next six months I
was like hey CEO I'm gonna need six
months off and she's like I can't do
that she's like doors open if it doesn't
work out you could come back but you get
in the tenderloins oh you guys did a lot
of people know you guys had years of
trying 16 years and I've also did a
couple of pilots that didn't take out
you know you know we had two one for
spike and then one for number spike is
that still a network I don't think it is
I don't think it is in the end of thing
just cars are crashing you know I know
it's a goose cars crash and then like a
music video segment you know it wasn't
like a top 10 worst list like then you
become one of those stations where just
did a countdown shows and stuff they
just rebranded it to paramount Network
now it's just like a regular channel
again okay it's not for men anymore
no yeah it was very especially for men
remember was the man well true when we
we joined true the slate was insane that
our show we have an honest
it was Harvey who's every Toshi towtruck
show three different titles Lizard Lick
towing south beach tow' and another one
that I forgot and then knock off shows
for like Pawn Stars it was called oh
yeah they had that I think it was called
pawn no what was it the major it was
like like the pawn brothers it sounds
like that so what have they had a show
and then it was our comedy like in huh
and now true was like a top comedy
network was just so so like weird that
that happened it's so cool that they
took that chance and it all like kind of
happened but I like if you looked at our
show on the beginning it was like what
the hell is this like wow how does it
even there so these guys gonna fit in he
fit in here no one and did you guys
worry about that or did yeah you did
yeah cuz we were on the table for MTV or
true Wow and but MTV wanted to make it a
strip show five days a week and recast
us and they were like we love the
concept
the show was great any other and now
they're basically the rob dyrdek Network
basically there's nothing on there Rob
beard yeah a hardcore pawn' hardcore
pawn' yeah that was it that was the
knockoff of so they they had their own
versions of things and they were all
success by a pretty successful in the
further their morgan if you liked tow
truck shows that's where you were going
oh yeah yeah if yeah if you like shake
it yeah repossession repossession
basically across the board and their
other big one was bait car remember that
[ __ ] show when they were just basically
like running like a BMW in the middle of
a project wooden door open it was
playing jay-z cooler full of beer it's
like oh what do you need all this I'll
get in it and drive away it was like a
parole officer in the back and that was
it's like they should have called
entrapment yeah every episode was just a
running car in the projects let's see
what happens let's see what happens
someone's gonna steal the car I don't
want spoiler alert yeah you know I don't
have to tune in it's not what CD Baby
it's not like I Ross irate you're gonna
get back together
this guy's gonna steal this car what do
you want to see what's your crime with
joy see II think if you have one man oh
mine yeah definitely embezzlement is it
really all for sure for sure its I love
like the whole like heist movie stuff
like I would think like anything that
like get weird
like like could you have done it in the
past nowadays it's tough for there's not
even much cash sitting around unique any
cash like if I could go back in time and
be any like sort of like pull off a
tease big scheme well I could definitely
be like a nice bank robbery in like the
early thirties yeah would you be already
working at the bank cuz I could see you
having that right and the little
changing chi-ching chi-ching
30 cents back that's all about that I'm
all about that life
1930s teller right here man yeah I'd be
a bank manager to get the inside scoop
you know that kind of deal then I'd make
them fire me in a fantastic way and then
I think I would know the lay of the land
and I would get my you know my next-door
neighbor involved yeah probably
blackmail somebody black not gonna be
fun - yeah those are the good old days
we key to a crime yeah before we had DNA
man oh man DNA rule would come for
everybody stupid science getting in the
way yeah back in the day we had to
actually do some detective work you know
cuz now every murder you watch the cops
have no idea until seven years later
where they can afford the DNA test
that's right it's like I'm never gonna
know anything about like that stupid
swab you mouth thing did you do that
like the 23andme yeah I did it we could
nail it in yeah [ __ ] up you did it I
[ __ ] up I would wait anyway I'm not
gonna be one of the people didn't do a
crime and like hide all the time I'm
gonna go - yeah that's what I like about
you yeah thank you right over you're
right up front all the time oh yeah I'd
rather go and get my time done and get
out yeah I don't well you said I did it
wrong I thought you maybe was like would
you swab that you did it wrong [ __ ] up
like what you're never exactly I think I
did the mouth yeah back in there like
wolfson it said Vaughn back that era
yeah it's crazy I think here cuz a lot
of people I guess they they're they're
attaching people to murders and crimes
you know because of that yeah I never
did it cuz I didn't really have an
interest because I feel like like the
only way they could find out if a parrot
is male or female so you have to have it
tested and I've had a parrot for a while
and I was like what difference does it
make to me I don't care if at least an
egg okay mystery solved if not no
difference yeah you know so for me I'm
like yeah I already animals differently
if they're male or female no do you have
animals I never have no oh well when I
was young I did but I'd never have as an
adult I'm but I meant
never have treated animals differently
whether we're male or female huh but I
get I remember asking like I'll ask like
a waiter like yeah is this fish male or
female sometimes if I order like a
salmon or something you know that's a
good one just to kind of see you know
and a lot of times they'll go check and
sometimes they'll come back with an
answer that's amazing yeah it's like uh
I guess there's no you know what I would
love in that scenarios when they came
back with an answer huh you just go
wrong and get up and walk out because
you know they try to pull long yeah and
open something up with a knife just show
a part of the fish what is that you tell
me that that's a fish deck yeah hide
something in there now you know alright
today's episode I got to let you know if
you if you're a gamblin person man or
woman or somebody that's between sexes
but they like to lay a little wager down
on something that my bookie is the place
to do it you know
people gamble they've been doing it for
centuries hundreds of thousands of years
a lot of times they see on cave walls or
fine hieroglyphs of people drew dice on
the wall but at the end of a hard week
it's great to sit down and just lay a
few dollars on your favorite squad you
know and especially since it's football
time and I wouldn't be telling you guys
to bet with my bookie if they weren't
the best do the smart thing if you're
going to bet this season in bet with
them they're my bookie if you're the
kind of guy that likes to bet a little
and win a lot do a parlay pick a couple
teams enjoy a whole weekend experience
better than this better than that bet on
something join now in my bookie will
double your first deposit use promo code
Theo to activate the offer that's promo
code th EO now if you have a gambling
problem I don't maybe think that you
should do it but if you like to gamble
and you can control yourself and handle
it then the place to do that at is my
bookie dot AG that is my bookie dot AG
today use promo code Theo to activate
the offer that's promo code th EO my
bookie dot AG play when get paid you
know I'm a become a new business owner
with
Podcast and and just dang with life you
know life gets busy sometimes and you
want to be efficient we live in a time
of efficiency and what if you could make
your work take less work that's a really
good thing well you can with kaptara
kaptara they help you find the right
software for your needs you have needs
and so you can get back to business
faster and you can get your business
done quicker it's just
instead of milling all around you get
right into the action kaptara helps you
find the software that will minimalize
the time you're spending compare
thousands of software options read
reviews and instantly narrow to your
favorites you'll have more time in no
time find the right software right now
to streamline your business at kaptara
capt e RR a.com slash th EO now that
could be maybe you have four employees
and you don't know how to delineate who
should do what and it would be better if
you had a system that helped you do that
kaptara can help you maybe you need to
sell something and and you need the
orders to be processed a certain way and
and then sent to a certain person who's
going to help you with distribution and
right now you got three or four you got
your grandmother in there she's driving
across town with the ticket and all you
don't need it you can tighten it up and
that's kaptara dot-com / Theo it's the
leading free online resource to help you
find the best software solution for your
business with over 1 million reviews of
products from real software users visit
kaptara comm slash th EO for free today
to find the tools to make an informed
decision for your business that's Capt e
RR a comm / Theo software selection
simplified and now back to the episode
with mr. Joe Gatto do you guys you guys
must run out of idea I mean when did you
run out of ideas obviously for your
shows
we've been when did you have to bring in
help we've got well it wasn't that we
had to is that we could afford - right
so in season we're going into season we
just wrap C's
and season 9 we start up in January and
we actually had our 200th episode this
season and like literally we had the
conversation at the end of season one
was like okay now what do we do like
because we were like so many ideas you
have to go through because never mind
the ones that make the TV right because
our episodes if you think about we do 26
episodes of season and there's three to
four bits per episode right so come out
of it yeah that's 14 million quick math
so like that's bits that you have to
come up with right and inside those bits
are jokes right so you have to do all
that and you break it down it really
could be very very it could be very
overwhelming so then we started to say
okay what what's just fun and what's
just funny what's weird to do so like we
went from that and we in this so much if
you think about like it's like let's
just try to hold somebody's hand see how
it goes and we would try with four
different people and we get four
different outcomes and there's a bit you
know and then we would start thinking
about okay instead of the goal of just
being in this or that let's think about
what could be something different and
one thing that we had was try not to
laugh like that when we broke that and
made that a goal that opened up a whole
new stream of things so it wasn't just
like oh only do uncomfortable stuff it's
like oh do [ __ ] that's really funny
that's gonna make your friend laugh and
if you can't laugh yeah so that opened
up like a whole thing and a couple of
our big bits like the carnage of cranes
Macbeth ketball where we say weird names
in the waiting room or like what we did
the two-way mirror we're like stuff's
going on behind you you have to watch it
a-ha and you have to continue to do this
focus group with somebody and not you
know so a lot of that happened one of my
favorites you guys did it's like a um
but I see what you're saying so people
so once you open up like a new kind of a
new yeah like edge to it you're like oh
here's a whole week a whole new world of
stuff we can do now that we have goals
now that we you have to try not to laugh
that's a hope yeah it's gonna do
everything you already did before and
then just make sure the other guys
aren't laugh and then we had to
establish our show long enough for the
first four or five seasons like we
wouldn't use an actor before that
because we want people to know and
believe it's that's real that's what the
show's got to be real doesn't work for
us right so somebody knows our show
they're not on it right so then we
brought in like actors as weapons where
we like one of the first pitch we did
was watch my grandpa like we'd be in the
we were in the mall and we had to
pretend we had to take a piss and but do
me a favor could you watch my grandpa
follow me and we had to talk him into
watching our grandfather and if they
watch him you win and we'd walk away and
when we did that
unscripted the grandpa's added such a
great element like they just went and
started talking yeah and it was like
this is really funny
so let's see what we do let's do that
with kids and okay now let's watch my
kid and then we start doing things in
that you know find my actor you know
like we would plant an actor inside like
like Marie was a waiter for one of his
punishments in Delmonico's a high-end
steak him yeah and we hit an actor with
a wig on and we're like you gotta find a
wig so he's walking around people's hair
is they're eating trying to find the way
and he'll be like well you know got a
deal
so all those little pieces you know the
first six weeks um you know the first
four weeks of our pre-production it's a
six-week thing the writers are together
our comedy get paid extra is a writer a
producer you do yeah yeah yeah so
they're there in the room and then we
come in for the last two weeks of the
six-week and we start hearing all they
pitched and then when we like something
we'll all talk it out figure it out and
then we'll start stacking it up and
being like okay here's our production
schedule so if you like to be the most
involved who is just kind of the most
like show up and either just they do it
every time and they it's just better for
them to be that way yeah yeah Q is very
much trusting of a he'll he'll also
he'll have his moment where he's like oh
I got this idea I won't do this but Q
for the most part when he shows up he's
like what are we doing today all right
let's get in there and do it yeah Sal is
very analytical oh he's he's a student
of comedy yeah you know he's really just
like that's the way his brain works he
really just but I always say that Sal I
normally get to the same place
I just get that way faster because I'm
I've got kind of guy I'm like this is
I'm very decisive like this what we're
doing this or not and he'll you know
just work out every permutation tell you
why it won't work break holes in it and
you know sometimes we prove them wrong
and sometimes you proves us wrong you
know it's like it's a good balance and
then Murr Murr is like in the middle of
all that like I would say Sal's on one
end I'm on the other and Murr is like
pretty much dead center but he has two
things he'll think about something for a
little bit and then get there or you
know he'll have ideas where he's like
that's funny that's terrible sometimes
I'll just say something it's like what
if we make Joe a massage chair right
it's funny
you know I mean you don't have to think
about anything like it's like it's been
funny to see it have stranger sent me in
costume and I'm a fake massage and they
make me this fake massage chair yeah you
guys have there was one was one of my
favorites that it's uh it's at a buffet
and I think it's like taking their
pudding bank loan people partake
a bunch of different ones one was
because I love the Facebook that's great
yeah when I was growing up they had
finally got a buffet in our town beating
people with [ __ ] loser dude somebody
shot out the windows but from the inside
dude that's how excited people were you
know it wasn't like a driver I get more
chicken let's do a [ __ ] win in there
you so fired up yes he couldn't stand
there being anything between him and the
[ __ ] Lord those who shot those
windows but yet I mean I remember yeah
buffets were everything man back when
you you know if we were in a place just
imagine they could have all that stuff
in one place yeah I remember I went to
Vegas my family growing up the first
time we went to went to a buffet in
Vegas and a Vegas buffet stand alone
oh I'll world class I remember dude I
remember
yeah our buffet was decently long I
wouldn't say it was real long but I
remember we were kids we were trying to
hold our breath and walk from one end of
it to the other you know just to trying
you know just because we were just a
name or by the length of you know food
and different pool like swirl or one of
the other yeah that's a salad yeah do
you remember when I don't know Wendy's
out in New York they they did the salad
bar which was basically a buffet but it
was open salad bar so you could just
make your own sell you buy the salad
bowl and it was all you could eat salad
why wait and oh yeah Wendy's instant on
that and they had a steady huge toppings
like but it's oh they had everything
like beside your croutons in your norm
they had like buckets it was like you
know it's just all these different
things on a flowers house they put
sunglasses right in seed you know they
get like but then it was like beets
that's how I was introduced to be
topping what's a corn dog it's like yeah
yeah so they like all these weird no
pickle anything yeah so it was like I
remember that and I remember being like
I'm gonna get a salad and I was like
that's an ingenious way to make kids eat
like like healthy cuz it was like a fun
way to eat salad you know right yeah
yeah yeah buffet man I remember the
first came so I used to get myself so
sick on shrimp cocktail like I would
just get so nauseous I would just want
to pop them things oh man did I write
the tales for the first two years in
restroom cocktails
nobody explained that day I'd eat the
whole tail no I did about choice day but
my good friend does
you know I'm Justin he was the DJ on the
cruise just injure a Stevie Issa tails
today yeah do one of my favorite things
from the cruise and we'll talk about the
cruise in a second um Michael Ian Black
so I went on you guys his first cruise
yeah
Michael Ian Black was on the cruise
right so he had to do bingo like
everybody on the cruise kind of you like
you performed and you also like did a
game or did something you were just
involved you know yeah and he did bingo
and he was like trying to be all funny
and stuff and the people they can't
apply a bingo they didn't give a [ __ ]
bro
okay came to play bingo man read it read
it lady beaten her cane against the wall
the real stakes all right yeah it makes
his job either she's just fired draw yes
it was so funny but it he he almost
couldn't handle the fact that it wasn't
accommodate it it's a comedy cruise on a
bingo cruise it was that was so much fun
Gilbert Godfried was on there and he
looked just like a baby that was on the
cruise ship to some lady had a baby like
like an 11 month old I look just like
yeah I did this I saw I did the good
picture it yeah yeah beautiful that was
where we hung out for the first time in
real like because we did the when we did
the comedy fest we hung out a little bit
there was a lot of people around there's
a lot of you and I spent a lot of time
yet on that first yeah that cruise was
great yeah that was great God that thing
was so much fun do you recall some
troubling thing you and I had fun on
that yeah yeah the game lüt the gambling
that they ran out of Chesley one like we
have to get more chips I'll go get Jim
people working there they just shut down
side him yeah that skill crane somebody
Elka I met two alcoholic guys playing
that skill crane on the ship and they
ended up making my t-shirts for about
four years really a couple beautiful
guys it's got Kevin and his brother who
actually ended up turning a little bit
green less time less time he's turning
green the brother but um but yeah
amazing people them but let's see what
they got here man hey Theo hey Joe my
question for Joe is
how do you think your kids are gonna
react when they get older and you tell
them what exactly it is that you do for
a living
are you looking forward to that are you
kind of dreading it that's a really good
question
should I impress myself well these
Millennials one question they figure you
know he knows the world I don't think he
wants an answer like I just crushed it I
will say that is a pretty good question
it is a good question I guess I wouldn't
think about that yes it embarrassing is
it I was definitely a shift when I had
my daughter and I was like oh she got
her father's gonna be doing this at any
of my comedy you feel different
responsibilities with comedy I think
when you have kids and you know that
this is what you're going your legacy
you know oh I see you're saying legacy
was always a thing with me always even
growing up him before I had anything I
was worried about what was I gonna be
remembered for really I was I was very
heavily yeah
yeah man some guy named was my man one
hell of a 2nd grader yeah that was like
I was like all I was very aware of it
you're gonna be known for not doing your
homework if you don't quit daydream
that's right so I was uh when I had kids
I was like all right and I feel like
there was sometimes there's only been a
couple times when I was in in the Edit
of the show and I was like I don't want
that to be out there for my daughter to
see one day or my son because our
company's always about us - it doesn't
matter in our our show is edgy it's like
I'm trying to make you fail so I'm gonna
tell you the most screwed-up stuff to
say or do or whatever but there's only
been a couple times where I like I don't
think I want to make that joke anymore
Alert or that because being a father
feels different yeah you know and it is
is that kind of stuff the the being a
father feels different is that stuff
that you can you couldn't know that
before no definitely I don't I didn't so
I don't know how other people did but I
think it really it's kind of weird too
cuz the other guys don't have that right
so it's like kind of like we're you know
I'm the father figure of the group which
is so weird and scary but like you know
like it's it it's your best friends you
always confide and have the same exact
journey
all right on the same ride my four
friends I'm the first every first big
thing in my career is with these guys
and it's their first two you know first
time we're playing Madison Square Garden
all together first four crews we did
together all that like all that [ __ ] all
the way through you know yeah and this
is like the only one where you can't
like connect with them
something about that you know so it
feels a little bit in a vacuum you're
trying to do your best with it you know
so I think that's uh that's where it
kind of weighs a little bit more hey
just try to rest has it been hard over
uh oh sorry let make sure we fully
answer this question did we get it Nicky
thing yeah yeah well I am what my
daughter does watch the show sometimes I
because I watch the edits at home and if
I'm working at home my office she'll
come in I just like you watching you and
your friends on the TV that says yeah
and I'll say I say ya know and then
she'll uh shoot you're just watch and
you know at the end we give a green
thumbs up or thumbs down and she just
doesn't she just sit there and watch it
and wait to the thumbs and if it's a
thumbs up she'll go yes and if it's
thumbs and she goes oh dad you got a
that he got a thumbs down and she got
like man so it's really what now I feel
the pressure at all I was like I can't
have my daughter you know that's so
that's gotta get but she doesn't really
get what's going on yet at all but I
think she'll enjoy she likes my humor I
make her laugh
oh that's good I can see that right
she's a little mini-me she looks like my
it looks like my wife my spirit really
hard wasn't me
arms up weird quirky laughs like get
anything like she's really very much my
do you see yourself having one of those
shows like the Australian guy that died
I'm talking about the very rare ones
daughter like taking over yet they have
a new show that's out now and it's like
yeah they're taking over you know I
don't I don't I think it's too big of a
gap yeah yeah between that I think you
know and and there's so many reruns of
our show who knows you know my time it's
over gonna have a bag of like 250
episode you can keep this thing go Holly
still be well yeah that's true huh I
remember when I was growing up I'm
trying to think they had some of my
favorite game shows on do you remember
the one where it was in a how it was
each it was like a fake house there was
three contestants they were I think a
team maybe three teams of two and there
was like fake house and then if they if
they got a certain prize or something
they would compete on the floor and then
if they got a prize and they then want
they had to run through the house and
get different gifts these boxes vaguely
vaguely remember and what you're talking
about it kind of felt like supermarket
sweep a little bit yeah a little bit
like that yeah
yeah but it was like yeah they had these
big houses and then they would put them
on this conveyor belt or something at
the bottom and they would open them and
see if they had one what we what box
they grabbed what was in it yeah like
and in the end they had a whole bunch of
boxes the final group and then they
would open them all and I think they
some of them could have money in him
it's basically like watching those
stupid Christmas videos you know those
stupid videos that are on now that all
the it's just videos of kids opening
toys and I don't want you seeing that
it's like the weird thing you gotta now
you watch one you're gonna don't do it
cuz you'll fell down the rabbit hole
it's just kids like opening stuff and be
like and all kids flip out and watch it
it's like it's good though but you'll
have to buy your kids toys you think
that's a good plane huh this guy's saves
your money man you pay for a YouTube
subscription you think rabbits are in
holes and like how do we get the [ __ ]
we don't do that yeah I know yeah we're
down here [ __ ] watching you you're
what over here that's my thing I'm down
here trying to live yeah what is stated
war throw a carrot down yes right now
I'm from a [ __ ] down here watching you
what do you think they say people hole
what did your rabbits talking to go you
don't go down that peep it oh yeah Jesus
I want out of people hole careful dude
Tenderloin everywhere somebody's got CD
they got dope everybody's got it I found
everything from mixtapes to friggin
pneumatics yeah mixed crotch yeah all of
it what that makes crotch um oh man it
was we got a question right here from
somebody who's in witness protection
actually let's get to this ever been
punched in the face for a plane a joke
on some money
okay I mean no no this how do you okay I
have questions how do you source this
material huh how do you source this much
open source how did you how did you get
this guy's video do you know this guy is
that no that's a fan of impractical
practical jokers we had a lot of
questions for you but a lot of them are
like kind of the same what's your
favorite prank pranks they're always
yeah yeah so have you ever been punched
in the face but it's not so much the
question is it's how the creepy guy in
the dark couch started marching his
fault very dark and also that guy could
be anywhere from the age of 13 probably
fifty one or two I was gonna say very
unique child's body Silver Fox the angle
to and it looks like a light shade of
lipstick on them see that he's got a wet
lips look at right there like see it's a
glistening lip he's got a wet lip
Jesus to answer your question no but
also I have so many questions yeah this
guy I wonder if he's alright yeah maybe
send someone sent a video that yeah
that's the people hole we were talking
about the rabbits are talking about I
remember one time I was working with
Howie Mandel on the show it was called
deal with it right and so I was working
this as a host for him for a while and
so you would get people off the street
and you would give one of them a they
would be coming to a restaurant and then
you give one of them in earpiece you'd
sneak them off the waiter when they went
to it with the bathroom or something
would be like all right we're gonna put
an earpiece and start telling you things
to do the more you can do without the
person at the table realizing you're on
a game show that's the only thing they
can't realize the more money you're
gonna make so one time we get a couple
to sit down and it's a pimp and a
prostitute we didn't know right so they
get the lady to starts messing with the
pimp right so they start telling like
little things to do and the third one
it's like okay reach over and take a PC
of man's food off of his plate or
something and she's like nope I can't do
this [ __ ] right and she I think she was
worried that she was gonna get abused
mm-hm
so we had to like we had to call call
the episode that's a very all them prank
the bit yeah but that was one of the
craziest ones that I ever saw we always
had trouble with couples we were in Ikea
and I didn't
I started a Friday night pillow fight
like I just gave everybody like 40
people doing a pillow fight all over was
fun
but there was they did a thing where
they wanted me this is my second Agua
story mm-hmm they want who they want me
to say they like Joe to help this guy
tell me he's got to see this
I'm worn you know how you know they have
that path in IKEA where you get run
right so they go and make this guy
follow so this guy started running
boards over here notes over here John
here and I just started basically
jogging around all this furniture this
guy was keeping up with me or whatever
and this is when I was bigger and fatter
and I was like I had a brother huffing
above lose 20 and then like get in the
armoire get in y'all more so me and him
getting the own more and it shuts all
you hear in the armoires me so it's like
whatever and it was really funny like
it's great so now we go to sign the guy
you know they have to agree to be on TV
it's right you know to party state where
they you could film somebody but then
they have to agree to be on TV in New
York in New York there's only like five
or six states that are that way so it
was a one-party state here I think
Democrat yeah yeah you have to let them
know it it really yeah yeah so let their
parents know yeah so we we actually
filmed out in LA for our 200th episode
it takes place here in LA yeah so was it
was a different procedure you had to do
like people had to know that they were
being filmed it had to be content in
closed space you could do any store you
had to be out in public or the cameras
had to be exposed like if somebody
walked in like this they know they're
being filmed it's fine right but then it
doesn't really work so yeah like we had
a couple things are weird but anyway so
we're in the on what we get out of the
armoire look dude you was so funny we'd
love for you to be on the episode and
the guy was like oh it's really fun he
said I can't do that he's like you know
I'm married and this isn't my wife so he
was shopping for discount furniture and
I bought a side yeah it was like he's
like I can't he's like and you know so
that was a weird thing that we had
happen and then that has happened
multiple times over filming where guys
are like oh I can't mister yeah I'm with
somebody that I'm not supposed to be
with Wow yeah you know what oh here's
someone else actually and this is
hopefully this person is all right hey
Joe hey Theo this is Tim from Memphis
Tennessee I'm a big fan of both of y'all
I want to be a comedian eventually
whether that's doing stand-up or getting
like a show like Impractical Jokers and
uh I just wanted to hear you guys his
advice on you know being a comedian what
do you do coming up
what kind of open mics or whatever you
know I'm 17 cell in high school I plan
on going to college but my dream job is
to do something you know like you guys
do and you can really tell with you guys
you're very genuine and you really enjoy
doing what you do and I want to do
something like that you know that's nice
attempt yeah sounds like a nice young
man
it's got great taste obviously it's true
and you and I yeah I mean the guys kids
a genius yeah well you said earlier like
you know it doesn't happen it doesn't
happen quick yeah it doesn't happen
quick that's the thing all you gotta
sounds well one of the things to happen
faster in my career and I'm glad that
they did in hunt side even though
there's no way I could have known oh
when no one and I would be like I would
talk to my managers in Asia I was like
why don't you know why does this person
get this opportunity and then you see
other people get opportunities where
they're not ready for them that's right
so that's uh that's a big big pitfalls
to compare yourself to other people yeah
everybody's got their own path if I got
their own journey if I got their own
time
yeah it might just not be your time yet
and also you have to be prepared that it
might not work out you know I was always
fine with okay the NAMM didn't happen
you know I still was doing it because I
enjoyed it yeah and I think that's a big
thing because no one could take that
enjoyment from you nobody has to
validate that enjoyment yeah you might
not be getting paid for it but you if
you're enjoying making people laugh and
that's it you know yeah you know it's
funny I've always felt that way and then
in the past like I think six months off
some of the things started getting more
stressful I think just busier and so
it's like I've had like an adjustment
period of like just figuring out okay
what's going on what do I want to be
doing what's really important to me
choices are the worst it's hard how do
you have a decision like if you want to
do this like that because you know that
you're leaving something behind you know
we went through that little bit with our
we figured it out finally but with our
movie only were in a film when we filmed
our movie last year we had to do it in
between the season so we filmed the
first half of season seven took a break
to film the movie came back and film the
second half of seasons and so we're
basically filming for like 16 months
straight on Bradway killers and like
being away from home and everything the
only way to do it was that or not do it
right and we're like are we gonna kill
ourselves and do it which we did or
we're just gonna be like alright let's
try to hopefully the movie you'll still
be around if we do it after season seven
blow
so when we had that choice I'm like
thinking about that it was always like
alright what if we don't and that I
always feels the heaviest year you're
always the heaviest there what that if
you don't do it it dropped you begun
right now what were the stresses that
I'm sure that was pretty stressful
especially if you had like young
children yeah I mean you're you know
that's a lot of time of straight yeah I
was you know I almost got divorced it
was tough yeah yeah for there's a
five-month five weeks away from home my
wife had a new newborn son my daughter
just basically like single parent and in
New York couldn't talk to her I was on
set for Sato different show I'm on a
movie set for 16 hours a day like an
hour she'll like I go we film for three
hours you know I would do some meetings
and stuff and then I could talk to her
the whole time you know here I couldn't
I'm in Atlanta right I'm away from home
you know that's such a Rhett's feel so
yeah that's intense like I don't know
yeah for me sometimes sometimes the
stress of too much work I've just
realized it's like it's too much
sometimes especially since I want to be
a comedian I want to be able to have my
thoughts and you know I need my brain
and come up with fresh fun ideas yeah
and if I work too much or if I'm
overwhelmed and stuff then I can't do
that do you feel like it changes you do
you feel like it changes your mindset is
a hundred percent and you can't not be
in a good mindset or in a good mood to
be funny yeah if it's impossible like
you're it's totally counterproductive
what you're trying to do and then that
frustrates you and you're like aw if I
wasn't thinking this way who everybody
yeah you go down a person hole yeah yeah
that happened me a lot this year man it
was just like just figuring out like
because we started podcasting so much
and it was it's all been fun but it's
like okay we're never was so now I'm
just I'm a podcast host or am i upon I
am I comedian and my you know what's
going on you know to the point cuz you
just you know I'll just go from one
thing to the next like go on tour come
back do and then go just be like I don't
even know you know started letting me
know what's going on yeah as long as
you're being creative I think if you're
a creator like I was it yeah but I was I
was creating but I didn't feel like I
was being created god I think I'm kind
of a slow I'm better if it's if it's a
little bit of a slow roll yeah
then we when it gets going too fast I
just I think I just can't hey I just I
don't know I don't function that well in
that space yeah
so some of us for me has been learning
where who went where how do I function
as a as an artist or as a communicator
but I think for this young guy I think
there's a lot of ways you can do
entertainment now so much more yeah I
mean you could put out your own videos
you can find you can you can even see
guys doing like voices of like mmm
they'll have animals that are fighting
yeah yeah they do anything yeah I think
but I mean if you think about like how
crazy like I wish like so much is lost
on these kids today as far as like
people wanted to do to do stuff and
everybody's always worried about you
know the followers and this and that but
if you just realize that this kid has
two heroes and comedy yeah and he just
because he has a cell phone as a camera
was able just to ask him a direct
question and they were talking about him
to him yeah that how does that not blow
everybody's mind how does that just not
like are you kidding me like that's
where we're at in the world well yeah
you have such access to people to
celebrities via Twitter Instagram any
pod oh yeah that's last night I'm a
Saints fan last night AJ Klein I'm a big
Saints fan yeah he caused a fumble last
night and a cinema man I was just so
[ __ ] ecstatic and he wrote me back
and I haven't even read I'm like saving
her it's gonna be like the highlight of
my day later yeah but yeah it's just
crazy how you can't communicate yeah but
and also just how you can create you
know and how you can put stuff out there
you can be an impersonator you can try
different things yeah you could try and
fail with no risk like you could try
like if you think about like back in the
day like if you want to do like a short
film yeah like you'd have to find the
money you have that you'd have to shoot
it you'd have to digitize it like
capture the tapes and bring it over to
your land you have to edit it and do all
the stuff then you have to put it out
where where are you putting it out yeah
they're like show people or send it out
yes Sally yeah you gotta do it now
no like and then it's bad because
everybody's bad and then you just go
ahead and do it every short film is that
every short film is miserable across the
board first one second wasn't always
better well like anybody's first short
film you'd be hard-pressed to find
somebody's first short film like that
was oh they're like the CBD oil of
entertained reel has the other day
I don't think CBD oil does anything
I was talking to so dick he's like yeah
I've been using a lot of drugs but I've
also been using CBD oil but he only
seemed like he'd been using drugs and
then I thought about like all the seamen
who have rubbed into my body and it's
like super it does [ __ ] man
I think CB d stands for snake snake oh
yeah well it used to be central business
district you know that was just a body
cream you know it's just I don't know
things have gotten strange but yeah I
think if you're 17 and you like humor
you know there's so many ways you can
end up in it but I do though miss I mean
my favorite things to do were to make my
friends laugh man you being at school
being at the lunch table that's what's
weird for me cuz I that is my job and
that's I still get that that's not taken
from me we always say like always like
oh I wish I knew the glory days and I
look we know this is the best job we'll
ever have this is the best scenario for
anybody that anybody in in the world
comedian or not you get paid to hang out
with friends at make them laugh like
it's insane yeah so like there's and we
can't really point a finger at many
other groups that had even a similar
kind of thing everybody else has cast
together well in any big successful show
was a sitcom and somebody's writing for
them you know it's not like all this
gonna make Sal laugh well you never said
that like I need right it's not like all
this good like that's there's a sense of
like accomplishment when you make your
friend laugh you know yeah yeah we see
oh yeah with you guys our show for sure
I mean yeah there's so many it's like
yes if you can always kind of relate
yourself to one of the characters you
always yeah every guy wishes they got to
do that with their friends
yeah what about what it was pretty funny
that one of our one of our agents was
talking and when they were going back in
for a negotiation like one of the points
at he was making you know what agents
always ramp themselves up by talking to
you you know so they're going in for I
think like season five or whatever and
he was like he's like tell me another
reality show where somebody's like oh
you know everybody always just say oh
I'm a Ross I'm a Rachael Ray from
friends or like oh I'm George you know
like that they're like people say I'm a
Sal he's like who cares that much about
a reality show he's a nobody cares about
that and this is like a little bit
around one of the Kardashian he's like
he and that was the only other one with
people were like I'm like that with the
Kardashian yeah and it was like nobody
does that what reality shows nobody you
know is like that everybody forgets the
name of everybody one is when it's over
in the season he's
guys on your fifth season your
characters but you're not yourself right
so he's like that doesn't exist and that
was always with the way you see the way
the fans interact with us they always
feel like they know us
oh my greatest fans of my comedy to this
day I think that I still meet up with
when I'm on the road whether it's for a
meal or something like that or fans that
I met from you guys uh-huh
Cruz no no yeah I mean that guy Kevin
there's a car there's a there's a girl
and her mom down in Florida I meet up
with them another group took me to
Disneyland one time that's awesome yeah
it's all I didn't know buddy busy you
are Disneyland I just took my daughter
it doesn't pay full price free ticket
though would you yeah I mean you get the
guy did you get the guy that takes me
yeah I get the guns expense but worth
every penny thing you know what we crush
that Park we have in and out of
everything was great yeah somebody told
me about that got to have my family
coming town and I was like and like you
got to get this guy yeah I talked to
Joey Diaz like you get the [ __ ] guy
you go over there [ __ ] look somebody
dies it's not on you papa
no no yeah they walk you in it's so it's
so great but the but at the same day I
was there Steven Tyler was there really
and there's this paparazzi that's called
I figure what's called on Instagram I
think is called day at Disney I think
it's called grand paparazzi yeah it's
like the day at Disney like Instagram
account it's like it's it's just celebs
Roy Disney and there's a picture of me
and my family me my wife and my daughter
but they blur out kids faces at respect
which is cool and it's me and them and
then the next picture is like Steven
Tyler born like a t-shirt you know just
in Maui and that's where he lived so I
heard all kinds of stories about him
while I was there yeah just uh and I
went and saw them actually I saw
Aerosmith about me and Nick went yeah
they're playing Vegas now right three
months ago we went saw dude it was
awesome
great yeah it was incredible he just
canceled a show last week they're still
doing like a Vegas residency because he
had a sore throat mmm so he could yeah
age finally catching up to him I guess
yeah what happens you know we all get
old all right don't judge so hard
do you ha ha this is Nick's first time
in the booth the booth is just open tell
Wow where
you normally sitting out there at the
table setup it was it was cumbersome
okay so you like this better
it's alright alright kind of feel like
I'm visiting you in jail right now Nick
probably should be in jail yeah so we
don't talk about that okay
has there been any points where where
any of the group has thought has you
guys had have had to talk anybody to
stay and people wanted to change or just
before we just before we did this just
before the show took literally like our
last meeting I was I was gonna be like
done with it and we were at my uh my
apartment we had gone down a path of
doing a lot of sketch comedy and I don't
really feel like I'm very funny and
sketch I don't feel funny when I'm
acting right no people I go you already
told me I'm like I just don't feel you
know a like so I don't feel like it's my
best way to make people laugh so I
wasn't really feeling what we were the
paths were going down scripted shows we
were thinking of in bulwa and I was like
is I gonna do that and then the
opportunity came up they're like hey you
know prank show was a big right now my
reason what if we did our version of the
show like that and I was like well this
embarrassment comedy is always how I
made my friends laugh sure let's try it
I mean that's how we came up we came up
with Jokers hmm
but if we were gonna go down to another
scripted one I would have been out
there's a guy I met one night at a bar
here called the mint it does uh I was
there for some I don't know something I
don't want to be at or something
probably um like I think now it's
actually a pet restaurant you believe
they have this [ __ ] out here really you
bring your pet me with it yeah or you
can meet up in a [ __ ] tent over the
other [ __ ] pops dude that's weird
I've heard it like cat place where you
could have tea with a cat they like to
just [ __ ] it's basically just feral
cats inside and they're just roaming
around you just sit down and cats like
sit on your lap while you drink tea yeah
you don't think Satan's watching it if
she's watching anybody it's people that
are meeting up with Casper taste by
themselves they've been dipping a
biscotti into an Earl Grey like that's
somebody who [ __ ] watch even more
than anybody I meet in the Tenderloin
district I do not want trust the guy
that walks in with his air pods
it sits down with a stray cat yeah and
it has a snack yeah somebody [ __ ]
splitting up a little butterscotch
biscotti with a [ __ ] Persian
word is original and I'm out I'm out
Jesus Christ man it's just a different
world but yeah this place they had a guy
I met in there one night and he he
starts talking he starts talking he had
almost White Glove and it karaoke in
there as well and at one point kick
casually Edie that wasn't gonna make
everything that [ __ ] at the war like
what are we brought in karaoke and one
of those indoor like skydiving things
let's do it yeah yeah
but it's a wedding but it's a wedding
you guys don't get it
so this guy he wore a white glove and he
kept saying karaoke and he had been like
the fifth member of a band that had made
it huge like I could have been Motley
Crue I feel like and he got out like
literally the week before and I went and
read the stories it's not about and it's
really and he was still singing the
songs and wearing like this white glove
like you could tell he was still like
living and I guess he'd kind of become
like a kind of a a fixture within that
karaoke place you know and so I think
you know he had like it you know at
least he had his thing you know yeah
yeah but he'd gotten out of this yeah he
gotten out of this group right before
that's I mean that's a little tragic
yeah if you don't recover from it you
know what I mean right
to get out of it because you want to get
out of it and not be in that world
anymore is one thing because then you're
okay with it no matter who cares what
happens but if you get out of it cause
you don't necessarily like the people
who don't you don't have faith in what's
going on with that group yeah you know
like I'll try it on my own and make it
that's all like that is the worst of you
like oh you know I'll just go humble
going my own way that they're holding me
back and next thing you know they break
and you sit there with your white glove
you know trying to serve no jell-o
pudding box the people that's crazy man
do you remember when you were a kid like
just some of the like just like the kind
of stuff that made you laugh do you
remember who made you laugh a lot when
you were kid you know yeah I definitely
even entertained or just people like it
just oh yeah people my wife my I come
from a funny family you know my uncles
were always funny and
claire's I got the old Italian uncle's
with your phone and you know my sister
is probably the funniest person I know
my sister Carla she's like she's a
virgin I mean like it's hysterical like
she's great she's loud she's fun my
parents were both very funny but in very
different ways and my they always said
my oldest sister got my dad's humor my
middle sister got my mother's and I was
the perfect match of both of them so
like my father's like that dry kind of
delivery could make room crack with
three words like that's it you know my
mother was just loud boisterous Center
attention everybody looked at her to
make a you know good time like that kind
of thing so they were very interesting
you know my father my here it started
well my father was he used to go we do I
play craps you know that like so I just
water right there if you need you know
okay we we you play craps all the time
and we've got a little annex city and he
when he was in the Atlantic City playing
and like the eighties or whatever and
this he's too gangster guys what's a
gauze at the end he's too big Italian
mobster like guys and he's playing craps
Nero but maximum and there's this woman
a heftier woman at the end rolling and
she's rolling and she's rolling for a
while and and the two guys are having a
good time so every time for she rolls
they're like all right come on you fat
[ __ ] then she did it like yeah you know
they would say that loud enough whatever
and so you know she's rolling and win
everybody money whatever and somehow
she's just about to roll like come on we
need a hard six you're fat but you know
come on you Pig like that and [ __ ] like
that
my father just turned to these two moms
it goes sorry guys could you stop
talking about my wife that way it just
turns back and looks and then he looks
Li goes I just [ __ ] with you and they
[ __ ] love these two like big fat moms
like that so he had that like that funny
like dry like they they're Gorge drop
like they look what the [ __ ] you know
kinda idea
so like yeah that sense that you were
like that where he would just like say
weird [ __ ] just like just enough to get
people really uncomfortable and then
break them so yeah that reminds me of
noir McDonald I was somewhere with him I
was and I was doing a show in Oklahoma
City or Oklahoma somewhere and he was a
poker tournament to Jerry Mathers is
rather believe Wow man who I love I
pictures all over them
room growing it because his name was
Theodore right now it sounds like a huge
fan and I even talked to Milo's air I
was like hey man I said I'm a big fan he
goes oh where do you live I was like I
live in Santa Monica and he goes swear
to God he goes I used to go get some
policy in Santa Monica
[Music]
I didn't know what happened then I
didn't [ __ ] it went down a hole it was
just crazy all these years that I built
up my head of us running into each other
that's the sentence and he's like he was
80 years old or 77 screws it was him and
that got Ralph Malph but anyway Norma
Donald was there and there's like we're
standing there as a but there was a lot
mostly men there and a couple of women
not attractive women to me hmm
norm said oh man a lot of real hotties
here huh and I'm thinking oh you know
norms older than me and you know he
probably don't even meet any women so
these women are probably very attractive
him you know and I was just play Kate
and I was like yeah yeah a lot of real
lookers you know [ __ ] I'll take my
eyeballs out just set him on one of
these ladies shoulders you know a lot of
real beauties and he goes yeah right and
he was joking he was totally joking like
he was like oh these are the [ __ ]
most boss okay someone for me a nice
year l yeah I went to Mel Brooks's huge
number one out number one I actually got
to meet him that was two weeks after we
had played Radio City and he was doing
he doesn't live tour every now and again
he still doing it 91 years old he shows
Blazing Saddles or Young Frankenstein
screens it and then does a Q&A after
flunking out ow so we went I took my two
sisters we grow up watch and I was like
for a Christmas gift I'm like I got this
for you so we went the three of us we
all grew up watching the movies was
great we watch them after we're about to
leave and I see the little security
guard that I had met weeks before when
we play real nice do whatever he goes
Joe I said hey he goes you want to go
down too you wanna come come in and say
hey and I was like yeah of course
Millbrook so he takes his downstairs
underneath Radio City there's just like
old bar that they just keep open for
family and friends and it's a big room
so we go down we sit in there and here
comes Mellie's walking in and he comes
behind I'm like oh this is like this is
my hero of all time or whatever so I
walk up and I'm like you know he's like
the guy who she's like this is our
friend Joe and he's like hey John was
like there's a bruxism huge fan of yours
I just wanna say thank you you know I
got a comedy because you you know you
made me laugh whatever I said me and my
sisters or both huge fans and our all
fans are and you know we grow watching
you and my sisters like well honey goes
your sisters I said yeah he goes I go
yeah my sisters they're here what may I
brought them and it goes okay again my
sisters bring the sisters and he pushes
me away moisture to me and it gets it he
starts taking pictures I kiss my cheeks
kiss my cheeks he stops taking pictures
my sisters it was so close I can I get
one you think he's like I just won and
we all got in and I was like that was
like the coolest like thing ever like
this ninety one old dude is you know
he's still going to get the ladies like
come here yeah it's so great really good
that's beautiful man it was a really
really cool moment from her van out a
little that age I loved it and I saw Bob
Newhart about six years ago oh really
or seven years ago in Chicago and it was
oh he was I thought the joke so I was
like I think he's just reading these
jokes off the internet like I think he
literally printed so he's all delivery
anyway right so yeah and I thought to
myself well maybe the guess they were
just like internet jokes yeah yeah so
but it was pretty wild to see him Don
Rickles means a guy really yes I knew we
loved Rickles my mom was a big gambler
and he was playing in Atlantic City
Sarge my mom to get us tickets and I
took him and was that awesome probably
one of the most unbelievable performance
like you can't even like you see it and
you're just like and all that it's
happening and then it's over before you
know it like you can't even was he on
stage whole time whole time was ripped
apart it was great yeah he was really he
was unbelievable yeah that's probably
one of the best live performances a day
but growing up I loved it like Richard
Jeni was big my dad liked Richard Jeni
the comic and he got murdered a got
murdered yeah they did this before
23andme so we still don't know who did
it and so uh he he was begging that Tim
Allen we still used to watch his show
all that home-improvement yeah there so
that was another big one for me um yeah
you remember sucrose
Supermarket sweet yeah yeah that shows
right I love I just got to play $100,000
pyramid me and they invited us to play
in the reboot that Strahan oh yeah so we
just plated this summer we played it was
it fun dude it was so fun so fun it was
so it was such a good time
yeah and now this is the thing about
through misery index like you're playing
a game show and it's like that gloss
it's like legit it's like a legit like
we walked in I was like oh my god this
is like spent some money on the set like
it's a legit like you think at the big
like you know it's the big display
that's like super led and like the the
buzzers and all that so I was like this
is really really cool to being part of
like a real like games yeah no yeah
because I grew up that I think all our
generations like that was huge for that
was that was TV oh yeah
no whammies all that was the stock
market sweep was so good no Suzy had
somebody just bite just running to get a
hand and yelling with them because they
get rice right there's one where
somebody had a stroke during and I
remember two really I don't know that
one you can't they don't really know it
on the show but it seemed like they
think the guys just kind of having a
blast but you could tell he had a stroke
I know a stroke you know don't bruise
easy one
I mean yeah I think I do I had one about
20 minutes ago I like to pace him out
pretty sure the guy glass is a question
with the wet lip was in the middle of
one any more questions that came in we
just had one patreon question
Marisa Bruno asked how did you become so
passionate about animals especially
senior dogs
my wife she introduced me to that we
bought a dog
I have five dogs I have a cannoli
biscotti
tartufo spumoni and pignoli right now oh
yeah I would put yoli's into routines
that a dessert that's like that's oh
they're all at some fan time so I name
all we also had zeppeli and Michigan who
are not with us anymore
god bless but we have like she we bought
our first dog cannoli
together when she was living here
because um she needed something and I
was like let's get a dog together so we
got her we bought the dog and then it
instantly was like all sick and we spent
like in the first year we spent like two
grand on like tests and surgeries and
stuff like that and she just like
started doing research and realize how
bad
puppy mills are mm-hmm and then like how
much adopt and how good how many dogs
are uneaten but once you found a lot of
good of adoption agencies so we just
started adopting so it was really
because of her and then I fell in love
with it on my own and then I honestly
believe that no dog loves you like a
rescue dog it sincerely feels like okay
yeah cuz Canole be walking around the
house kind of entitled like you'll call
them I'm last universally like I'm here
now you know like that right you know
but like the other ones like they're so
always so happy to see when I go home
it's insane because I'm on the road you
know yes I when I come home for my ten
days or whatever on the day it's I can't
get them off me it's insane like they
just attack you and want to be on y'all
you sit down they're all jumping on you
you know you lay in the bed they're all
on you dance crazy yeah yeah it's not
spud it's it's good and do you trust all
of them no there's one I know that [ __ ]
man really no it's actually it gets easy
when you have a pack like biscotti who's
my favorite they listen if they're
listening they know so this guy he's my
favorite she's the second one and she's
like the the pack leader it's easier
what if I like I'll bring in a dog once
biscotti shows what to do they it's
insane they just alright we all go we'll
go in this room now we all return to go
outside they wait they just follow her
really crazy as she looked up at little
little pack later and for them to be
able to pack like that do they have to
be the same breed of dog or anything
Wow no there's a couple of tricks that
you do for do if you're gonna introduce
a new dog in the house it's better to
have the dog in the house by itself for
a day and then when the dogs come home
the dogs there so it's like a great
trick that we had found out in the
beginning so I'll send the dogs away to
daycare or whatever and they'll sleep
out and then we'll have the dog make it
move around the house or whatever they
come home is Dalton house that's it it's
insane you know it's just okay they're
part of the family that's it and do they
have any like racial or kind of
territorial issues between them the
animals just one there's one it's time
to go to bed Wow who sleeps where yeah
cuz I lay we have a you know we have a
king bed and my wife's on one side and
then little pignoli who was like I got a
picture up in your lab that animal out
here bro you could draw it too always
had something like this this is this I
just want your reaction when you see
pignoli because pignoli something
special but pignoli is in our rotating
spot we have we have a fifth dog spot
which is this senior spot and that's
open yo Lee can yo Liam working
I always got one out yeah we used to
work on the highway basically roadkill
that's his role no my house sweetest dog
in the world man super cuddly but she
they found her in a tenement building
just in the ball matted in the in the
lobby I've been living under the stairs
so they don't know they think it just
maybe just came out of somebody's
apartment and whatever but she's got no
teeth she's deaf blind one eye a little
bit dementia oh wow one of these wrecks
but she's she's super cute and cuddly so
we just we'd like to for the senior dog
we just kind of give him a good way out
like we had a couple dogs before this
that one lasted seven months one lasted
a year in a little bit and pignoli we
have four about what I got pignoli two
months now yeah about two months now
have you this last question I have so is
there have you noticed like that like
your success and stuff was there any
point in your career where you felt like
it started to kind of change you and you
had to kind of like see what was going
on with yourself or was there like where
you got like no I think that in a bad
way no no just in a way anyway yeah yeah
yeah it's a huge thing man there's a
thing about when you become famous and
strangers want to want your time and
energy right and you have a family I
think that was a thing for me like it's
like Hado and I still struggle with that
me my wife are very open honest about
like I don't know like when I have my
daughter with me if if you see me when
I'm out with my family you don't get the
same me when I'm not with my family
right right because I'm trying to be
protective of my family unit right and
this is spend time and energy with them
you know so I think that's the one thing
that I've always been trying to figure
out and my wife we never I wasn't trying
to be famous right I'm we met and got
married like I wasn't doing this you
know when we got together you know I got
married we were in it but when we when
we got together I was a Salesman
so this kind of got thrust upon her as
well to be like oh your husband's gonna
be famous yeah so now you have to share
them with the world
so it was like [ __ ] yeah you know I'm
just trying to get 20% that's it you
know you bond you know now now she's got
to deal with this so I think that's
probably the biggest challenge but the
good thing about getting famous together
with your friends is everybody keeps
each other in check yeah you know your
your boys see that on you smack you know
what you doing yeah I could see that
well that's one thing I seen about
improvident that then one thing is a
little bit different and abusers kind of
buy yourself a lot
so with improv the error with your group
you know with with the tenderloins and
with the Joker's it's like you guys have
that group yeah the group mentality
helps because if somebody starts going
their own way it's like compass God is
like hey if this guy brings back then
I'm like you know yeah uh Joe thank you
so much is God o or gado-gado yeah yeah
no this is great man I really appreciate
it dude thank you so much man you've
always been
just one of the every time I see you I
just remember what a console you are so
appreciate you coming man thank you
yeah it's an honor and uh yeah you guys
have so many friends dude how do you
keep everybody I know y'all's friends
yeah you know we tried you know that's
not like I'm not that way when I'm out
in LA like especially if I'm able to get
together some social stuff I try to make
sure I see and there's some people I
like to see when I'm out here because
it's good to keep in contact with people
like I said earlier you know this
there's a commonality between us that
it's kind of fun and I'm enjoying that
like I'm in the being in the comedy
world what people that make me laugh and
yeah stuff this is we have cool
opportunities like they had people work
with us and work with people you know
it's fun yeah it's cool man
yeah it's a good point too I love it man
well I'm grateful you came here today
can I ask you for one favor
yeah my cousin Michael palana was a huge
fan of yours yes yes a huge friend
Michael Pollan Oh Michael Polanyi he
works in yourself yeah he's he's a he's
my cousin and he's a cameraman and isn't
it true that you guys know everybody for
your neighborhood work on your show such
a nepotism is really literally like as
so many like people
well somebody work for us for free for
so many years I was like had to be like
love that though it's so great
Michael Pollan Oh huh that hitter grow
up to send us something nice and you one
day he actually almost blew out here in
a calm yeah he's a teacher where in
where he's in Jersey where at Ocean
Township High School just be in
Salyersville coming up sometimes you
know how far away they know it's not
that far
it isn't yeah yeah and he said he's at
the said gang gang he did what does he
teach television production does he go
that's awesome going on there that's
great it's great on the kid there mr.
Paul Anka that's his name pal I know mr.
Palin oh yeah that's awesome man
I would take his class like what if he
in there
Gang Gang Mike thank you thank you for
sending a thank you for sending gentle
my way Mike I appreciate it man and uh
whenever I get over there the jury's out
to pop in yeah you know pop in the class
I might be cool oh that was they would
lose their mind you kidding me yeah well
now kind of sentence well no I mean I'm
all the way here from New York yeah all
right we'll figure it out where we'll
make something work I love you dude
you're all love you too man thank you so
much bro you got
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
oh ma
[Music]